would you like to be my friend
forever and ever and ever and ever
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to social interaction
trainer now much like you I don't talk
to people well that's presumptuous of
you I look like a dick now I'm sure you
talk to people real good
I'm just projecting my own social
ineptitude on you guys don't let me
override your social butterfly nature
anyway so I don't talk to people good as
was evident just now but thankfully I'm
in a room by myself not wearing pants oh
my groin well this is off to a good
start I can do better than that hang on
ha those key is he no pants what I'm
Everett back up a bit what I'm trying to
say is that I need help in talking and
living life I need to know how to do
these things I need to know how to
social circle
I don't do it do good so this game is
supposedly supposed to help me that use
your gaze to socially interact with the
cashier I don't think I don't think
that's supposed to be helpful
hey yeah I ordered one ham
thanks for the ham what the [ __ ] did I
just do
urinal lightly use the public urinal
alongside a urinating neighbor
maintaining a house it's dissuaded in
this situation lalalalala nice dick
lalala lalalala
do not allow your gaze to wander off
from your task oh I should be looking
where I'm peeing
oh he glances at other genitals to a
minimum there's a tolerable amount of
genital glancing but not a lot okay all
right staring down at mijeong looking at
meself go to the pier that's not the
words you're supposed to say when you're
taking a leak but I don't okay that
wasn't scary as flushing sound I've ever
heard in my life well I'm off to a good
start
let's go transport whatever the hell
that means I guessing I need to get
relatively warmed up before I get into
any like deeper elements of conversation
here strike up a conversation with your
transport partner hi you look pretty oh
sorry
she was creeped out by your attempt at
social interaction well what else is new
I'll just go bury my head in the sand
take my pants off and keep yelling at
the internet someday that'll make me
friends la la la la
ah back now all right so what do I do
hey hey hey it's a pretty lady over
there okay nice book okay nice boobs
okay your hands are nice okay I like the
way your ears look okay
I like the tuft of hair on your head
okay will ah nice book I'm just looking
at your book your book so engine Bobby
go buy the book
yeah you gain for a romantic interest oh
yeah if it was that easy I would've done
a long time ago
hey we're gonna coffee whoa boobs oh my
god boobs oh my gosh their boobs
oh my god boobs oh it's impolite to
stare at a person's breasts I don't know
about that all right make good
impression on the first date ba bap bap
bap bap bap bap bap wah wah wah wah you
are too intense
what do you mean those too intense BLAP
BLAP BLAP can I stop can I stop you
looked at the cleavage too many times
what I didn't look at the cleavage at
all is looking at that painting on the
wall and the dog on the floor the talks
looks up Hawks looks up talks and looks
at boobs huh okay everything good
alright anyway oh ah buh buh happy
they're big doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
huh look deep inside yourself for the
answers you seek oh oh I have to act
like a goof
yeah I was wondering what was going on
okay hey herb yeah you're laughing hey
that was a good day you glanced at the
cleavage one time
I don't even remember doing that oh this
is going wonderfully I am doing good at
the social interactions and being able
to talk to people and girls and stuff
let's go to the park enjoy the more
comfortable second day well I don't know
about that it's probably just gonna be
as uncomfortable yes I know
Hey I must stare you down
bah hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
you acted too strongly the situation
escalated well what happened I could
have beat them all I I substitute all my
social interaction skills with physical
violence yeah yeah yeah yeah man man Oh
avoiding this situation doesn't help
well what did I do I wonder if all of
life's problems are solved by crossing
my eyes what oh well hey I defuse the
situation with humor all of life's
problems are crossed by your eyes what
the [ __ ] did I say all right we can go
romance her too oh hey this isn't
something that should be cackling
maniacally - but I just feel the sudden
urge to don't mumble on your breath
kind of fusion with humor okay I can't
handing blablabla purchase condoms
you're making the cashier uncomfortable
with your staring
there's no way to win this man map con
doms Dom's Dum Dums
Don's dumbs hey I bought him good for me
yeah oh ah I don't know I was prepared
for this one okay all right doing the
awkward dance right on out of here
goodbye everybody okay see you
boos look at those boobs this is weird
what the [ __ ] is happening I don't know
oh god she's bored yeah I guess oh boy I
was looking at the boobs I guess oh yeah
oh my god boy where where right there
hey right then you really know well your
partner found your lovemaking to be
romantic you really know what you're
doing well hey I've had exactly one
previous opportunity of practice and
that's good enough free to become a
master at anything so good on me I
played a lot of huniepop so I know
exactly where the glue just one they
want color matching puzzles convince the
interviewer to hire you I don't know
wool this ah yes Brad uh hey well Oh God
are you as awkward as I am oh geez oh oh
hey oh the interviewer was put off by
her cucumber nosed face you won't be
getting hired I know what I did wrong I
got hired for a menial labor job and I'm
super gonna be happy about that forever
and ever and ever anyway I'm glad I have
funeral and baby to look forward to the
first one after the second one which is
great don't embarrass yourself on
meeting her parents well I find your
daughter
sorry was the dog comparing the breasts
of your girlfriend and mother should be
kept to a minimum I didn't do me bad
make good impressions with her father
okay
hey dude nice
I I did not do that waiter or maybe I
did do that yeah yeah we're men and we
like too far that's us that's good oh
can I still fart hey yeah oh I endeared
myself to her mother oh I better not
[ __ ] this one up okay congratulations
you've been warmly glancing the family
after glancing at a dog of reassuring 29
times holy [ __ ] I went to that dog a lot
alright work performing oh my god I love
those boobs crap oh my god and Allah
Allah Allah Allah Allah well bat bat man
that bat yeah k become friendly make him
laugh dude look at me I'm a lapis
preparator black boy brap brap BLAP BLAP
BLAP but back it's my one skill I've got
it and I got nothing else
hey make him laugh again oh oh
maybe this yeah that's it oh not looking
not looking oh my god those moves I've
gained a friend through sexual
harassment now thats ghetto no with more
one more funny
wait oh I've got to make him stare at
her boobs
yeah oh my God look at those boobs look
a little bit of that how about that yeah
you like that don't you yeah I'm doing
something some going on whoa what I did
I was trying to get him to look at her
boobs I was trying to mentally I think I
don't know what I did there
but I won and that explains why I need
to go to a funeral all righty then pay
your respects I don't know if I should
hey you're dead I'm still being funny oh
this guy was a dick but we have two sig
buh oh my god oh my god Oh God uh well
that's no good I don't know how to pay
our respects
oh it's impolite to imitate the
disability of a dead boss at his funeral
okay down yeah what oh god he's looking
at me oh no oh that ain't right Oh a
good person oh hi um I don't know that
this is Bo's oh why is he looking how is
he looking this isn't my social
interaction anymore okay
whoop oh there they go then okay
alrighty then I guess we're done there
Oh what the [ __ ]
okay why the [ __ ] Evan Oh what did I do
okay oh all right then
hello what do I do for you what up what
am i doing why am i being all crackled
okay
I see the eyes okay alright okay okay
maybe why why there's no clues there
console what if I fail this okay if I
fail this I'm freakin out of here
okay yes maybe yeah
congratulations you didn't make the
funeral worse yay I did it somehow if
you ask me how I wouldn't know but it
has something to do with random eye
positions just like life everything's
random and what you do doesn't matter as
the outcome is you're gonna live and
then you're gonna die yeah hopefully in
the middle you have sex somewhere let's
have a baby
versus diapered babbitt barber boom hey
right now
come on yeah whoa hey hey oh god ah [ __ ]
then blind to fall asleep I hand her
welp that did it quick you're supposed
to make quick circles I think
hurry up lady oh we're not getting any
yeah all right be a father
I don't know how blue doo doo boo boo
doo bomb a bomb a bill on my daddy look
at me I'm a funny daddy look at me look
at daddy oh oh oh it's a baby nothing
prepares you to be a parent your child
will grow up to be an ass well okay what
is that the moral the story here
well there was nothing I could do there
yeah I think that's the end of it well
[ __ ] well there you go it ends there so
I'm assuming that's what it is
so that was social interaction trainer
now
I know that I can go out into public
life and become the social butterfly
that's always S&M a number one I'm gonna
stare people boobs a lot until they love
me I'm gonna raise my babies to be dicks
and then make fun of my dead boss at his
own funeral as his eyes go wishy-washy
in every frickin direction so hope you
guys learned something here cuz I sure
didn't but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching go out
into the world and feel confident and
free and whatever you want to do so
thanks so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]